vous êtes un astronaute et vous voyagez
à vitesse lumière sur le compteur plus
de deux cent quatre-vingt dix-neuf mille
kilomètres par seconde
vous êtes aux limites des lois de la
physique rien ne peut théoriquement
aller plus vite que la lumière
du coup problème si vous avancez votre
bras pour appuyer sur un bouton ou que
vous tapez ensuite il dans les couloirs
vous aller plus vite que la lumière non
c'est ce paradoxe qui nous a fait
questionner sur un tel voyage
à quoi ça ressemblerait de pouvoir aller
à la vitesse de la lumière
quelles en seraient les effets sur notre
corps et que pour y tombe bien
expérimenter le voit-on en voyageant la
vitesse lumière voilà comment ça se
passe dans star wars mais c'est toi qui
s'étire un vortex bleus et pouf vous
êtes arrivé à destination
bon dans la réalité ça se passe pas
exactement comme ça à vitesse lumière il
y a trois effets sur votre vision
premièrement les formes vont changer à
vitesse lumière ton champ de vision va
s'élargir
tu vas pouvoir voir la terre n'ont pas
ronde mais comme si c'était une carte
mise à plat tu verras même ce qu'il y a
derrière les choses comme cette face
cachée de la terre quitté normalement
invisibles
comment c'est possible à vitesse normale
quand vous voyez disons une tasse vous
ne la voyez pas vraiment vous captez les
photons qui ont rebondi dessus et qui
ont atteint votre oeil mais les photons
de cette passe il en rebond 10 dans tous
les sens c'est juste que vous n'en
captait qu'une petite partie
c'est ce que permet la vitesse lumière
sur votre trajectoire vous aller capter
en un seul coup quasi tous les photons
émis ceux qui partent en base ceux qui
partent en eau et même en avançant peu
ceux qui partent de derrière l'objet
quand même un angle mort vous voyez pas
360 degrés c'est comme faire un mode
panoramique sur téléphone et s'arrêter
avant la fin deuxième effet les couleurs
vont changer
tu as déjà entendu une ambulance quand
elle s'éloigne de toi le son devient
plus faible mais surtout plus graves
l'explication c'est les ondes sonores
avec la vitesse elle se dilater
paraissent plus grave c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'effet doppler et bien la même
chose peut arriver avec la lumière
parce que
lumière est aussi une onde l'équivalent
du sang grave c'est le rouge et
l'infrarouge l'équivalent de légumes le
violet et l'ultra violet or plus notre
vitesse se rapproche de celle de la
lumière plus on raccourcit les longueurs
d'onde qui soit en face de nous on les
tasses on les compresses le monde
devient donc violé l inverse les
longueurs d'onde derrière nous ces tirs
les couleurs virale infrarouge et donc
pour notre vision humaine tout est noir
ce phénomène a un nom scientifique
l'effet doppler extrême pour illustrer
sa un groupe du hem haïti a fait un jeu
slower speed of light
le but est simple vous êtes un enfant
fantômes qui veut absolument voir ce que
ça fait d'être un faux tant il pour sa
récolter des orbes magiques qui vont
réduire la vitesse de la lumière
relativement à lui ce qui va lui
permettre de voir comme un photon la
vitesse d'une marche normale comme vous
le voyez le mont passe bien aux bleus et
aux violets notez quand même que les
humains deviennent rouges
pourquoi bas comme vous le savez votre
corps et mes de la chaleur est tentée
infrarouge invisible normalement mais en
l'état sans en les compressant vous
rétrécissent et leur longueur d'onde
vous les rendez visible en rouge donc
ainsi devant vous il y à des ultra
violet est derrière des infrarouges est
entre les deux eh bien vous aurez tout
le spectre visuel qui se tasse aussi aux
non cet effet arc en ciel comme dans
cette vidéo
enfin ça c'est juste théorique dans la
réalité vous ne verrez juste aucune
couleur pour la simple et bonne raison
que les photos vont s'accumuler dans vos
yeux au point de vous donner une vision
toute blanche troisième effet incapacité
à percevoir va changer immobile votre
champ de vision et 224 degrés mais avec
la vitesse sur l'autoroute vous avez
peut-être remarqué que ça se rétrécit
autour de vous ça devient floue car
votre cerveau doit traiter trop
d'informations aient choisi de se
concentrer sur le centre de l'image on
appelle ça l'effet tunnel en voitures à
130 kilomètres heure vous ne voyez plus
qu'à 30 degrés dans un avion de chasse à
2400 km heure c'est à un degré pour vous
donner une idée de ce que ça représente
coller une pièce de 10 centimes sur le
mur puis écartez-vous de deux pas la
pièce représente le champ de vision tout
ce qui est autour ne sera pas traitée
par votre cerveau vous voyez le problème
arrivait
la lumière est un million de fois plus
rapide qu'un avion de chasse votre
cerveau n'aura le temps de traiter
aucune information maintenant qu'est-ce
que ça fait tous les effets cumulés
c'est très difficile de trouver des
simulations correct est satisfaisante de
ce qu'on voit à vitesse lumière a
défendu le gard isation on est obligé
d'éliminer certains aspects la meilleure
existante a été faite par des chercheurs
pour la télévision allemande et
s'accumule bien tout ce qu'on a dit le
rétrécissement de notre vision
l'accumulation des fautes on au centre
et les images qui vont passer vers
infrarouge sur les bords et l'arc en
ciel entre les deux quels sont les
effets de la vitesse lumière sur ton
corps en voiture que tu ailles doucement
au rapidement tu sens pas la différence
tu peux lancer une balle sur le siège
avant te reviendra pas dessus
théoriquement à 99 % de la vitesse de la
lumière c'est pareil tu pourrais vivre
tranquillement à vie à l'intérieur du
vaisseau il n'y aurait aucune différence
mais qu'est ce qui se passe si on monte
à 100 % qu'est-ce qui se passerait si tu
venais à lancer une balle
théoriquement on rappelle rien ne peut
aller plus vite que la lumière
et c'est le cas aucun acte hommes ne
pourraient bouger la balle serait figé
c'est contre intuitif je sais mais à 100
% de la vitesse lumière
vous êtes plutôt comme les parts de la
voiture si vous les allumés à 100 km
heure ils vont pas aller à 100 km heure
de plus que leur vitesse lumière et ce
petit paradoxe à un effet jusque dans
votre cerveau vos pensées ce sont des
signaux chimiques et électriques
ils sont liés à des molécules et des
particules qui ont une vitesse
or vous l'avez compris ils vont pas
aller plus vite que la lumière
si vous commencez une conversation et
qu'en plein milieu vous appuyez sur le
bouton vitesse ultime tout votre
équipage sera figé et à l'arrivée vous
reprendrez la conversation comme si vous
n'aviez jamais été interrompu ce que je
viens de dire n'est vrai que si vous
atteignez 100 % de la vitesse lumière
disons qu'on est à 99,9 29% genre on km
heure de moins que la lumière si je
lance la balle elle ira plus vite que
les 1 km heure manquant et elle va se
figer dans les airs non non elle va
atterrir normalement
pourquoi parce qu'avec la vitesse vous
allez dilater le temps vous avez
forcément déjà entendu parler du
paradoxe des deux jumeaux
deux jumeaux se séparent l'un reste sur
terre et l'autre voyage un an à 99 % de
la vitesse lumière à son retour surprise
le jumeau rester sur terre est devenue
plus vieux que lui de 7 ans cette
expérience on la teste tous les jours
dans l'espace des satellites fils à six
kilomètres par seconde 1 50 millièmes de
la vitesse lumière ce qui décale leur
horloge de 35 micro secondes tous les
jours et faut pas croire c'est un
véritable problème car ça décale les
positions de votre gps sur terre qui
doit les corriger constamment ce temps
perçu par rapport à un référentiel il
peut se calculer avec une formule est
comme vous le voyez plus vous allez vite
plus le décalage s'accélère il tend vers
l'infini
ça nous amène au problème numéro un de
cette vidéo e égal mc2 si les photons
peuvent atteindre la vitesse lumière
c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de masse alors
que vous ben si vous pourrez donc jamais
allé à la même vitesse que vous pouvez
vous en approcher un genre 99,2 dernière
pour cent mais jamais l'atteindre
vous allez devoir mettre une énergie
infinie pour atteindre une vitesse
infinie donc comme on l'a vu sur cette
courbe
vous finissez par indéfiniment dilater
le temps vous vous souvenez quand je
vous ai dit que vous pouvez lancer une
balle même dans un vaisseau qui va 1,1
km heure de moins que la lumière
c'est contre intuitif normalement la
balle devait ce sujet et bien non le
temps l'empêchera simplement d'atteindre
la vitesse lumière la trajectoire de la
balle sera normal sauf qu'en regardant
depuis l'extérieur du vaisseau
c'est comme si elle était devenue
extrêmement lente le temps s'est
ralentie dans un référentiel données
comprenez bien la lumière n'est pas une
vitesse fixes c'est une infinité hors de
portée
si on part de ce postulat ça donne
quelque chose d'assez bas dans le photon
qui a été créé à l'époque du big bang
pour lui c'est comme s'il venait mettre
pour lui tout est infiniment dilate et
l'infinité du temps apparaît devant lui
comme une seule et même image
ils et elles dieu or de toute
temporalité humainement compréhensible
vous ne voulez pas voyager à vitesse
lumière
appuyez sur ce bouton c'est la garantie
d'une mort assurée pour quatre raisons
d'abord l'accélération et le freinage
passé de 100 km/heure à zéro lors d'un
accident de voiture
ça vous transforme en crêpe accélérer de
0 à 200 dans un avion de chasse
ça oblige à des entraînements de fou
pour ne pas s'évanouir
cette accélération la mesure angers et
vous vous demandez probablement quelles
sont les limites atteignable par l'homme
et bien quelqu'un a testé pour vous john
falstaff s'est attaché à une fusée pour
voir le résultat
passé de zéro à 1400 kilomètres heure on
n'ouvre seconde 40g d'accélération ça
fait mal son squelette était en morceaux
cote coccyx poignée tout casser ses
organes ses yeux ont quasiment explosé
il a été aveugle pendant plusieurs jours
et bien pour passer à quasi vitesse
lumière en une seconde c'est 100
millions de chez ça veut pas dire que
c'est impossible
il suffit juste rallonger le temps
d'accélération prenons un g c'est ce que
tu ressens dans un looping de montagnes
russes
et bien si tu peux supporter ça pendant
936 jour tu arriveras à 99 % de la
vitesse désiré mais une fois qu'on y est
deuxième problème les obstacles à
vitesse lumière impossible de les éviter
planet soleil astéroïde vous allez tous
vous prendre en pleine poire mais
imaginons que vous arrivez à trouver un
itinéraire de pure vide spatial
eh bien ça ne suffira pas l'espace n'est
jamais vide on trouve au moins une
particule tous les centimètres cubes
cp oui mais à ces vitesses c'est
suffisant pour vous tuer à 99 % de la
vitesse de la lumière si vous entré en
collision avec une poussière
l'énergique de l'impact serait
équivalente à une explosion d'une bombe
nucléaire
les poussières des toiles étant partout
l'espace serait pour vous un champ de
mil nucléaire mais disons qu'on a passé
l'aspirateur sur votre chemin et que
tout est clean
bon bah toujours pas car troisième
problème les radiations un simple
contact avec un atome d'hydrogène et
nous voilà lui transférer tellement
d'énergie que son noyau deviendrait
mortellement radioactifs hydrogène c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus commun dans l'espace
127000 atom dans chaque mètre cube de
guide
c'est ce qui se traduit par une dose
radioactive relative de 61,6 verte
toutes les secondes en permanence
l'homme ayant reçu la plus grande dose
de radiation au monde c'est isasi ouchy
je vous passe les photos mais toute sa
peau s'est liquéfié est détaché de son
corps pourtant il n'avait reçu que dix
sept si verte
au total le seul moyen d'éviter ça ce
serait de vous faire un bouclier en
plomb de 4,4 km d'épaisseur ce qui
augmenterait exponentiellement le nombre
de collisions
bref la destruction assuré mais il y a
une dernière raison pour laquelle vous
ne voulez pas aller à la vitesse lumière
l'expansion de l'univers
on va dire que vous avez eu de la chance
aucune planète aucune poussière
aucun atome d'hydrogène source trajet
vous avez réussi à vous mettre dans un
vie totale de matière eh bien il se peut
que vous rencontriez un destin plus
funeste que toutes les morts décrite
dans cette vidéo
pourquoi parce que l'univers est en
expansion hic il n'y a aucune limite à
sa vitesse pour le comprendre mais tes
deux fourmis sur un ballon gonflable
si on roule très vite le ballon les
fourmis s'éloignent les unes des autres
à une vitesse supérieure à leur propre
vitesse de marche
imaginez maintenant que les fourmis
c'est la lumière et le ballon l'univers
qui se dilate du coup en voyageant un
peu trop longtemps et un peu trop loin
de la terre à vitesse lumière vous
finiriez par devenir plus lent que
l'expansion de l'univers traduit plus
simplement vous êtes piégés pour
l'éternité
telle est la punition pour avoir voulu
égaler la vitesse des dieux une prison
sidéral éternel un long rêve noir
[Musique]